this is a site-specific wall drawing by
Vargas Soares Universal a Brooklyn based
artist which is curated by the Wallach
Art Gallery but a collaboration with the
Miller theater here at Columbia
University the first collaboration ever
between the two major presenting art
spaces on campus
Miller Theatre serves as the front door
to the campus and over the course of the
year over 35,000 people come through
this space and we liked very much the
idea that we would Commission a living
artist in the same way that we
commissioned contemporary composers to
write music for our series here at
Miller Theatre that we would Commission
a visual artist to make a piece for that
space when Deborah and Melissa
approached me I thought that it made a
lot of sense that art gallery theater
you know they're two such important
cultural venues for the university here
and so it just made sense to me for us
this is a really wonderful opportunity
to dialogue between a contemporary
artists and the music that's going
inside the Miller Theatre and Rafael
Vargas forest was the perfect first
project to do in this lobby space once
these walls were painted black it really
made the art to stand out most of my
work is based on a type of translating
or coding of geometry from scientific
information mostly from astronomy and
mathematics and in this particular case
referencing musical notation it was so
much fun working with Raphael you know
we met him pretty early in the process
Deborah had known him and had worked
with him for a very long time and so she
you know she selected him knowing that
he would be the right match for to work
with us and to work in our space and so
he was basically in residence for four
days before the opening and kind of
working from you know dawn until dusk
and past dusk to create the peace in our
space usually cultural centers have all
this leftover material leftover paint so
I told I told everybody here just
go to where you have the paint and we
literally mixed all the black paint they
had together when I first came to see
the side I realize how how central and
how public of a place it is and as I've
been working here there's people coming
in and out and so I have gotten a
clearer sense of the amount of people
coming through here so keeping that in
mind it it was a matter of doing
something that making a composition a
visual composition that was really also
about what's going on here and we
decided to take the black paint around
and what happens is that it gives it an
extra dimension and it makes it look
soft like maybe it's something soft
because if you just go to the edge and
leave it straight maybe it'll look like
a hard plane we have a variety of
different series here at the theater and
so every time there's a new audience
that comes in and they're seeing it for
the first time there's there's an
excitement and we can see that people
are traveling through the entirety of
the lobby so it's not if they come in
and go directly to the box office or
come in and go directly to the
performance but they take time to linger
and to really experience the work and
hopefully we'll have opportunities to
work with other artists going forward in
the future here in other spaces on
campus it would be great to live in the
campus up with contemporary art and
different different spots outside the
wallach art gallery